hey what's up my name's Samuel Leeds and
if I was starting out from scratch as a
teenager to get rich this is exactly
what I do and firstly I did start out as
a teenager I'm not twenty a I started
out when I was 17 I was financially free
by the age of 21
meaning never having to work again and I
may be biased a little bit toward this
particular Avenue but I think it's
because what it's what I know is what
I've done and if you look honest a bit
on the rich lens it's well pretty much
all of those guys are involved with in
some capacity and that's property I
think properties like the best
investment so I'm starting as a teenager
let's say I'm 15 years old
how on earth am I going to get into
property as a 15 year old teenager and
only get into it I mean get into it and
achievement but how am I gonna actually
get rich from property starting out as a
teenager well here what do I mean
firstly let me just say as a teenager I
think you actually have a massive
advantage because when you're in your
forties and fifties and you've got a
corporate job you might be making 80,000
pounds a year for kids two cars two
holidays wife
what happens is you cannot have become
you enter into the rat race and you
become trapped with that because you've
got to sustain this lifestyle the Jones
is a next door and you want to keep up
with those you've got two kids they're
depending on you that might be
employment school
so doing anything new and pursuing and
new avenues I see we'd risk it
however when you're a teenager or a
young person in general the massive
advantages you got nothing to lose you
haven't even entered the rat race yet
which is a good thing because it once
you're in the rat race even if you win
the rat race
you're still a rat so I think teenage
being a teenager or a young person is
not necessarily a bad thing so how do
you get into it well there's what I
would do I mean people think it's no big
deal going on a gap year you know you're
gonna get me is no big deal to spend 40
thousand pounds
on University which is gonna fall yes
this is no big deal you know so what I
would probably do is I would drop out of
the school because I don't see what the
big deal is about school anyway why
would you study hard at school with the
purpose being to get good grades that
would then give you a job and a job is
then gonna give you money and put you in
the rat race like why why would you do
that so I would drop out of school
fifteen years old I would spend three
months working on a building site that's
what I would do and this is kind of what
I did I did work on a building site and
why did I do that and why would I
suggest doing that any teenager because
if you work on a building site you're
gonna you're gonna get an idea of what
he's doing to a house I mean ultimately
if properties create wealth then you've
got to understand properties and what
he's doing to make a bad property of
good quality
how much does that cost and this is all
stuff that you'll learn on a building
site so I would spend the first on that
is that here's a challenge one year get
rich and as a teenager started from
nothing so first three months someone's
been on a building site and I were just
studying you know the craft of
plastering I did that line it up to
plaster learn how to brick lie all this
source stuff once I've done that for
three months I would then spend three
months working in an estate of an agency
again I did this I spent three months
working or countrywide I'm working in an
estate agent and they negative to say
what why do that because when you're
working on this state and I got out of
work now okay I understand
the crooks in the bricks and mortar of
Reles day now I want to understand what
makes a good investment and why why does
that make it a good investment and when
you're working in an estate agency
you'll be finding and selling houses all
day long you'll be speaking to investors
that are saying you know they're looking
for houses and you'll get a good idea of
what a good property isn't investment is
also an estate agent and alayan agency
I've been wanting to do I wanted to work
in a bit of both because I'd also want
to know how do you find a tenant what
makes a good tenant and how do what's
the process of managing that cannon so
by now you do three months in a building
site now three months in the state of
Maine Agency you're gonna add those
people say three up three months you
know people say I've got 20 years
experience as an estate agent and the
truth is that that person has actually
got one years experience photographs 20
times because you you can learn things
we quickly you can pick up the ropes
really quickly I was the stayed up after
three months I felt like I kind of
learned everything I was gonna learn as
an estate agent they learn a little bit
more and I could have been there yep
after a year you've done so three months
building side windows standing property
in bricks and mortar and what needs
doing to make a bad property good how
much it costs three months understanding
what a good property investment is
working in an estate agent and know the
image is working about how to find a
tenant and how to manage your tenants
what she did that for six months along
side that alongside those six months of
working six days a week in my lunch
break and Japan in my evenings and
weekends because they drive into it of
course you're not driving because you're
a teenager and I think some people will
think oh I can't drive listen man like
there's people with disabilities that
can't drive there's people but have got
no arms and legs and a multi
millionaires like really successful I
mean that's why they learn six months I
would also be reading books I do you
believe in myself personally really
things like Think and Grow great
because when you when you have okay so
you're working on your job for free by
the way cuz you're 15 no one's gonna pay
you so you're out you're gonna have to
beg people for a job this is what I
would be if I starting over again at 15
years old wanting to be rich I'd be
begging to work for free I'm being
titled
don't be thinking you know a little
payment or oh I'll ask three people and
then if no one gives me a job no one
lets me be a volunteer then it means no
one well no I'll ask a hundred people
please can I work these of three for
three months and listen it's not
difficult it's just called work
experience people all were to pick those
businesses all the time looking for
people to come work for them for free so
sweet months on the building site you'll
be the dirtiest jobs could be mixing
cement and stuff like that three months
is going to set you up for life in
property three homes working on the
state and letting agents alongside those
six months I've been reading books like
Think and Grow Rich of course I'll be
writing my I'd be reading my own books
apart from they wouldn't exist if I was
starting over again so I've been I've
been developing myself personally I've
been beginning to think rich also a bit
learning how to sell so important so
you've got these you're these hard
skills over here which are all that
property in this skill aspect and then
over here you've got soft skills which
are more like sales negotiations
communications basic business how to
think rich and alongside those six
months not only what I've been
developing myself personally by reading
books and learning the skill in my in my
job which I'm known for free but also be
are they going to property networking
events and I'd be finding out what are
investors looking for the building up
relationships
hey I'm 15 and I'm working for
understand agent anyone wants to have a
chat become a speak to me and then I'll
be just speaking with people I'd also be
wanting to have a meeting you know you
kind of meetings with accountants for
free
he's even starting at two years old my
little girl you can have meetings with
accountants for free I've been meeting
up with an accountant when I want free
they don't charge you for a one-off Mia
so we go meeting on the counter anything
why would I want to meet you you're 15
I'd say on Thursday but I'm working in a
letting the state agency and I'm going
to all these property events and I just
don't have a little bit of an
understanding about some bigs half an
hour and over half an hour with the
accountant which I'm eating for free
I don't know how do you set up a company
and how does packs work how do you pay
taxes I don't want to get a meeting with
a solicitor and I get free me and if you
can't get a premium as mr. ring another
one and then another one all the
investors that you met the property
networking event I'd say have you any
meetings with a solicitor to come and
jump in you know just make it happen how
hard is it find G's people do a lot
harder things and arrange for a
solicitor to meet them for half hour
most the legal process of buying a house
I've been meeting with a mortgage broker
for half an hour and just figure it out
how does the finance work can you
explain it to me please I'm 15 years old
you know well the end of those six
months geez it will be the best half gap
year of your life financially they just
would people go out for up for a year
you're gonna do stupid things or study
up for four years at University and
spent twenty five thousand pounds I
don't think nothing of it
you're working for free six months
building site let your agent the state
agency go to property events and meeting
investors me and solicitors mortgages
accountants brokers get to understand
the process of buying a house what makes
a good investment what are people
looking for networking
join I joined BNI business networking
international I mean that cost so maybe
everything I was it up into this point
is free but maybe maybe you could agree
when you're working for an estate agent
you could say as part of a part of my
job can i network and you can you pay
for me to go and join a network
anyway ended there six months you're
gonna be valuable and that's how you get
rich and then what are you ready damn
you 15
maybe you just turned 16 now all right
you understand how to how to value a
house you understand how does it have to
add value how much things cost you
understand what makes a good property
investment how the finance works how to
set up a company you understand all that
but you choose to buy a house you team
to do anything what do you do at that
point it doesn't matter you can do so
much value what I did I would with the
following six months excuse it's all
within one year following six months six
months then I would say and my name now
to find ten really good investments and
what I would then do is I'll marry those
temp investments up with someone who had
money I ask them if they want to do a
joint venture hey I'm just 16 years old
but I've got experience working on a
building site in an agent yada yada yada
yada yada I've got this fantastic
property investment these are the
figures here's the sheet of all the
think of them and you've got money and
I've got time I will work as a free
labor on the house to fix it up
I will then find and manage the tenants
in the house for free on this house on
the basis that you buy the house and you
let me be a 50% shareholder I'll manage
everything albrecht 5050 all the profits
I mean how many people have you got find
maybe maybe if you just want to
investors that one five of those each
ten houses in the following six months
you've suddenly got ten houses you only
are involved with them but the average
house is 200,000 pounds ten of those is
two million half of that you're 15 years
old you've got a 1 million pound
property portfolio boom that's what I'd
do
[Music]